[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: And so today,
I'm ecstatic to have
a prolific person with
us today, Malkia Cyril.
Before I introduce Malkia,
I'll introduce Wilson White,
the host of our panel today.
Wilson is the Public Policy and
Government Relations Director
on Google's Public
Policy Team, where
he counsels the Android,
Google Play, communications
and hardware businesses
on public policy issues.
He also leads on the company's
global policy strategy
for emerging tech issues
around artificial intelligence,
virtual reality, and
the Internet of Things.
Malkia.
MALKIA CYRIL: Didn't
do none of that.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Malkia Cyril is
the Founder and Executive
Director for the Center
of Media and Justice.
A co-founder of the Media
Action Grassroots Network
for decades, Malkia has
strengthened the organizing
and communication capacity
of grassroots leaders
to show racial and economic
justice in the digital age.
A prolific writer,
public speaker,
and poet, Cyril's
articles and quotes
have appeared in "Politico,"
"The Huffington Post,"
"Essence," and dozens
of other places,
including documentary films
such as Netflix's "13th."
Cyril is a Prime Movers fellow,
recipient of the 2012 Donald
McGannon Award for work
to advance the roles women
and people of color in
the Media Reform Movement.
The 2015 Hugh Hefner First
Amendment Award Winner
for framing net neutrality
as a civil rights issue,
and the 2016 EFF Pioneer
Award for the leadership
on digital civil rights.
Born of parents in the Black
Panther Party, a resident,
and originally from Brooklyn--
MALKIA CYRIL: Brooklyn!
SPEAKER 1: More
specifically, Bed Stuy,
Malkia is now one of
the few leaders of color
in the movement for
digital rights and freedom,
and a proud leader in the
Black Lives Matter Network.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I present to you
Wilson White and Malkia Cyril.
[APPLAUSE]
WILSON WHITE: All
right, so I think
we're going to have a pretty
fascinating discussion
with Malkia here today.
In terms of how
this will work, I
will get us kicked off with a
few questions back and forth,
and then kick if
off to the audience.
I think people on livestream
can also ask questions as well.
But just to kind of
set the frame for this,
I did not grow up in
Brooklyn, New York.
I grew up in a very small
town in South Carolina.
Attended church every day,
grew up in the AME Church.
And whenever I'm in
a setting like this
where I have to moderate
something or give
a public talk, I'm reminded of
what my pastor told growing up.
Which is, whenever
you're doing this,
you've got to
remember the five Bs.
Which is, be brief,
brother, be brief.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
Taking that advice
from my pastor,
I'm just going to jump in.
We've heard a bit
about your bio,
but I'd like you to give us a
little more context and color
on where you've been, and how
you ended up doing the work
that you're doing at the
Center for Media Justice.
MALKIA CYRIL: All right.
Well, thanks for asking.
Can y'all hear me all right?
I don't know about the
whole mic situation.
But I was born in
Brooklyn, Bed Stuy.
And those who may go
to Bed Stuy today,
you have absolutely no idea
what it looked like in the 19--
in the mid-1970s and the 1980s.
Because then it was a war zone.
Then there were heaps
of trash burning
and large tenements that
were completely undealt with.
It is the largest
black community
in the country, black
neighborhood in the country.
It was one of the
poorest outside of--
in the Northeast,
black neighborhoods
in the country, and I
lived on the corner.
Now, I don't know-- anyone
who grew up in a hood,
like in a ghetto,
in an urban ghetto,
knows what the corner is like.
Because that's where
everything goes down.
And I always asked my mom,
why would you move us here?
Why would you-- you were
in the Black Panther Party.
You knew all about the black
liberation and black power.
Why would you move us to a
place where we could die?
You know?
I felt like that was
a legitimate question.
And she would say to me,
well, I could move you
to a white neighborhood.
I could send you somewhere
where you would fear yourself
and other people like you.
I could put you
in private school,
and you could grow up with lots
of chances, lots of whatever.
But you wouldn't
have fought for that,
and those chances
wouldn't be chances
that then anyone else
around you, other people,
were able to receive
because of you.
So we're here in order
to fight for our people.
It's not just about you, and
it's not just about your life.
It's about our lives together.
And it was a hard lesson
for me, because as a child,
it's like, no, it's about me.
But she made it very clear from
the gate that it's never just
about me.
Another funny thing that
she always used to do,
or that I think this story
gives you a good picture
into how I came to be here.
So it was mentioned
that I was poet.
So I wrote a chat book.
I got it published by
Kitchen Table Press, which
is the press that Audrey
Lorn, and Barbara Smith,
and folks who were originally
affiliated with it.
And I was about 13
or 14, and my mom--
it was all my mom's pushing
to make that happen.
She bought all these
copies of the book,
and she's like, yes, now
let's go to Restoration Plaza
and sell these books.
I'm like, OK.
So I go to Restoration Plaza,
which is like a little shopping
area in Brooklyn.
Sold all the books.
I make like $1,500.
I'm so excited.
I'm like, yes.
I got money in my pocket, I
didn't even have to sell drugs.
I'm rich-- $1,500.
So I bring the money back,
and she's like, OK, great.
And she peels off a $100
bill and gives it to me.
I said, I'm confused.
WILSON WHITE: Yeah, $1,500 is--
MALKIA CYRIL: I sold $1,500
and did all the work.
And she said, you know
when you have a gift, that
means you have to give it.
It doesn't belong to you.
All of the rest of this money
is going to the local women
and children's shelter.
And that's what happened to it.
So that's like how
I was raised, right?
You know, it's not
just about you.
It's about your people.
When your body is on the
line, it's for a reason.
And so my mom was a member
of the Black Panther Party.
She ran their breakfast program
in the New York Chapter.
She also was editor for the
"Black Panther Newspaper."
So she taught me really early
on an appreciation for art,
for culture, for words.
She believed in journalism.
She was an educator.
She ran out of the
wider community college
in New York all of the
educational programs for folks
in prison in New York.
So that is where I come from.
And so coming into a focus on
media and telecommunications
technology, [AUDIO OUT].
WILSON WHITE: Having
that background--
MALKIA CYRIL: Yeah, it
was very easy for me.
WILSON WHITE: We're
saying that background,
the context from your
upbringing, how that made
the transition into what
you're doing in terms of media
adjustment was fairly easy.
MALKIA CYRIL: Yeah.
So let me crystallize that.
So number one, in the '80s,
news coverage was filled with
stereotypes about
superpredators,
black teenage superpredators,
black crack babies,
black welfare moms--
black, black, black criminals.
And that was about me.
That was about me and my
friends and my family.
And so as I became an
organizer, my first mandate
was always to address
this question of me
and how the infrastructure
of meaning--
the news, the
education system, all
of these pieces
of infrastructure
that produce what we read,
watch, and listen to,
how they're implicated.
And they are part of the problem
if what they produce actually
results in these criminalizing
policies, so on and so forth.
So that became my focus,
laser-sharp, as I moved on.
But I realized that I can't do
anything about the narrative
problem if I don't address
the structural problem
behind those narratives.
So that's how I came here.
That's why I work on technology
policy, media policy, and all
of that.
I'm not a lawyer.
I'm not a policy wonk.
I'm not a technologist.
I'm an organizer who cares
about how meaning is produced
and what that means for
black and brown people
in this country.
WILSON WHITE: Very good.
So I want to stick
with that theme.
So in preparing for
this talk, I had
this wide-ranging discussion
that I was prepared to do.
And then on Friday, the verdict
came down in the Castile
shooting case out in Minnesota.
And I felt like having
this conversation with you,
I'd be remiss if we didn't
talk about that case,
particularly as
it relates to what
you do in terms of the media
and narratives that come out
of the media.
So, of course, I was hurt by--
I still am-- the verdict
itself, a verdict of acquittal.
Not because of that
individual case,
but because it's the next
chapter of essentially
a law-abiding citizen being
killed by a police [INAUDIBLE]..
This was the next
chapter of that.
But what I was most struck by
was the media response, or lack
of response, to that verdict.
Is the media just exhausted
with these killers?
Is society exhausted?
Why is that?
MALKIA CYRIL: Look, we're
dealing with 400 years
of anti-black criminalization.
So that is going
to show up in how
news talks about the murder--
and I will continue
to call it a murder--
of a black man on Facebook Live.
Everybody could see it.
So let me back up.
So number one, I
always say that you
can't extract 400 years of white
supremacy from any institution
simply by adding technology.
So people thought that by the
fact that you could watch--
WILSON WHITE: Yeah,
cellphone video.
MALKIA CYRIL: --the cellphone
videos, Facebook Live,
body-worn cameras.
The fact that you could
watch would somehow
increase the measure of justice.
That's not the case.
Watching is not justice.
It's just watching.
So I'll say this.
Number one, I'm hurt.
But I also understand that
this is a structural problem.
These news outlets are at
the very top, mostly white.
At the very top,
they're mostly men.
That is just the fact.
And so when it
comes time to make
editorial decisions,
about, number one,
do you take the official
word of police as the truth?
That's the first question
that often these journalists
have to answer when they're
reporting on these cases.
So, for example, the
sister who was just
murdered yesterday in Seattle--
a pregnant black woman
called the police
to report a burglary,
opened the door.
She had a knife, presumptively--
presumably, rather, because
she was being burgled.
She thought she
was being burgled.
She had mental health issues.
They shot her almost on-site.
She's dead in front
of her three children.
WILSON WHITE: Yeah.
And she called the cops.
MALKIA CYRIL: She called them.
And whether we're talking
about black men, black women,
our Muslim brothers and
sisters across race who are
being murdered by vigilantes.
Because I want to really
also say that police--
it's not just the
official police.
It's also those who
feel that they've
been deputized by this
heightened white supremacy
that we're dealing
with right now.
So whether it's the
official police or those
who feel they have
been deputized
by this type of policing,
we are dealing with a moment
where anti-black criminalization
is being pumped up
by media coverage.
It's being sustained
And I think that these
outlets have a responsibility
to be very clear that the
police narrative is not
the official story.
Let me just say this.
The title, the headline when the
woman was killed in Seattle--
so yesterday.
It said, "armed woman
killed by police."
How do you know she was armed?
Was there some video?
It's just basically
the police statement
that they built the
headline off of.
So this is the kind of
practice that we have to end.
This is the kind of
practice that news outlets
have to stop doing right now.
I don't think it's fatigue.
I really don't.
I think it's racism.
And I think that
they've been reporting
like this from the gate.
This is not new.
So that's where we're at.
We need to directly
confront any outlet that
has an editorial role.
And that's not just news media.
That's also social media and
other kinds of technology
companies that curate that--
WILSON WHITE: So let me
stay there for a second,
because I'm still
processing this.
And I saw the news of
the Seattle incident
yesterday when that came
across the wire as well.
So this is still top of mind.
So as a lawyer, I know there's
Supreme Court precedent,
at least in this
country, in the US,
that gives law enforcement
significantly--
I think the standard
is something
like law enforcement officers
can discharge by standard force
if they believe or have a
fear that the suspect poses
a threat to them.
So even if that threat
is that this person is
going to charge
them with a first,
they can discharge their
weapon and kill the person,
almost with impunity.
And that's kind of written
into a Supreme Court precedent,
which, as you know-- and that's
kind of what you stated here--
by having that fear be
part of the legal standard,
it almost bakes in that racial
bias into the legal standard.
So from an organizing
standpoint,
because you are an
organizer, what can or should
we be doing to try to put
pressure on the system
to change that legal standard?
Which, I think,
in a lot of ways,
is the reason why we
don't see convictions
in these types of cases.
MALKIA CYRIL: I think
that's a great question.
And I don't think anyone
has a very clear answer,
to be honest.
I think that,
first of all, let's
understand that some
of the first police
officers in this country were--
their job was to catch
runaway slaves and to patrol.
Their purpose was largely
to capture runaway slaves
and patrol for runaway slaves.
Early legal precedent
dictated that a black man
has no rights a white
man is bound to respect.
All of these legal
standards have
been baked into how we
think about and deal
with policing in this country.
And so when you
ask this question,
what can be done to extract or
to add pressure to the system?
Number one, there's an
entire legal strategy at work
that folks are using, both
in terms of trying to--
so there are lots of
places where lawyers are
trying to attack the system.
One of the places
that organizers
are trying to
attack the system is
by changing who our prosecutors
are in different cities
and states.
So there's been an entire
campaign by Color of Change
to transform the face
of prosecutors and DAs
in this country.
I think that's one way, right?
But we also see that in
Baltimore, when a district
attorney tried to actually
convict some officers,
not only did that
not happen, but she
was completely outcasted and
also made into a criminal.
She faced criminal charges,
because that's what
the system is set up to do.
And it's not set up--
so when we talk
about police reform,
when we talk about, for
example, body-worn cameras,
this is one place where there's,
I think, a false solution being
offered, where you're
offering to people
this opportunity to
record, but that does not
invest any change.
There's no change
involved in that.
These piecemeal
reforms are not going
to make it so that police
don't kill black people.
The only thing that
will make it so police
don't kill black
people is if we are
able to abolish policing
as we currently know it
and rebuild it
into something that
actually has a new
form of security,
new forms of accountability.
That's the only thing that
I think is going to work.
We can attack-- we can run
our various legal strategies.
We can make piecemeal reforms.
But we can see--
right now, the
Justice Department
is actively rolling
back any reforms
that have been moved forward Any
consent decrees, any of that.
So in reality, what
we know is this--
it's a question of power.
Who has the power will
determine what the results are.
And two, these piecemeal
reforms, they just don't work.
We've been trying them
for hundreds of years.
They do not work.
WILSON WHITE: I want to
clap, but I'm the moderator,
so I'm not supposed
to be clapping.
[APPLAUSE]
I agree with that, Malkia.
And I think that is a
significant challenge
for our country.
And so, personally,
I'm glad to see
that we have soldiers like
you on the battlefield,
pushing these issues and
raising our consciousness
on the importance of making
sure that that kind of stuff
is done.
I'm going to try to get off my
soapbox on the police shooting
issues for a second and switch
now to one of the things
that you've been
very outspoken on.
And that's net neutrality
as a civil rights issue.
So net neutrality is
certainly an issue
that we are in the thick of
as Google, as an internet
content company.
But this notion of net
neutrality as a civil rights
issue.
What do you mean by that?
MALKIA CYRIL: Well,
let's not get off
the soapbox of police shootings,
because net neutrality has
everything to do with whether
or not police can shoot and kill
us with impunity.
Here's the reality.
I don't care about Netflix
versus Comcast versus--
I don't care about
these big companies.
You know what I'm saying?
I honestly don't.
What I care about
is Philando Castile.
I care about whether
or not you'll
be able to see this shooting and
have the spark of outrage that
can turn into a wildfire
of protests, that can turn
into a movement for change.
Because the thing is that
without being able to see it,
you can't do that.
That's the bottom line.
And for me, that's what net
neutrality is all about.
You know what I mean?
For some people, it's a
contest between major companies
and who can get
the fastest access.
There's a question around
what the market can bear
and what it can't,
and regulating
that and all of that.
And that's for other
people to talk about.
Somebody else can come and talk
to you about those specifics.
I'm fine with that.
For me, I only care
about net neutrality
because it opens the
door for more mobility.
It opens the door for black
people to speak freely.
It opens the door
for us to bypass
what I consider to be a--
not what I consider to be.
What facts tell us is a
white-dominated cable news
media.
You know, entertainment media.
From entertainment
to news, right?
That we're able to
bypass those gatekeepers
and speak for ourselves.
That's what we've been
trying to do from day one.
When we built the first
black press and white writers
came and burned it down, we were
trying to speak for ourselves,
to plead our own cause.
And that's what we're
trying to do right now.
Now, there are some
who profit from the--
let me say this thoughtfully.
There are black organizations,
Latino organizations,
Asian organizations,
who have decided
that the only way to and to--
I want to be real thoughtful
about how I speak here.
But that the only way to make
their money and be sustainable
is to partner with
telecommunications companies.
Now, the thing is that if you've
been alive for the last 10
years, you also know that
those same organizations are
fading in significance.
That a generation is
emerging that wants
more than a partnership
with the same companies that
are denying them mortgages.
We don't want to just
partner with Wells Fargo.
We don't want to simply march
in parades with the Homeland
Security.
That's why we protest
at gay pride parades.
They're like, but you're gay.
I'm like, not that kind
of gay-- born black.
You know what I'm saying?
You know what I mean?
That's why we protest,
because it's not--
we're not interested
anymore in receiving
their handouts in order
for us to get our freedom,
because it won't
lead to our freedom.
So net neutrality for me
is not only an opportunity
to divest from that
kind of corporate power.
It's also an opportunity
to invest in black speech,
in black-- in a different kind
of black power, 21st century
black power that allows
us to not only speak
freely, but create our black
businesses that we create
online.
When people talk about
Black Twitter, it's like--
I hate that.
Because you're giving all the
love to Twitter, but black
is the part that is making it
interesting and profitable.
And it's the content
creators that are--
they might speak on Twitter.
But actually, they're bloggers.
And they have
their own websites,
you know what I'm saying, that
create all of this content that
then becomes the--
that gets the name
Black Twitter.
So that's what I mean when
I say net neutrality is
a civil rights issue.
It's an opportunity to bypass
structural racism in media.
It's an opportunity to
bypass economic racism
and create online.
It's an opportunity to
build movements and build
political power that is
decentralized, distributed,
and doesn't rely on
the Democratic party.
And I think that
that is something
that we need more
than ever today.
WILSON WHITE: Well, we see
the current administration
is taking steps to kind of
rollback some of the steps that
were taken on the net neutrality
conversation previously.
Do you think that this
position, this perspective
on net neutrality as
a civil rights thing,
as a divide issue, do
you think that's getting
the type of audience that it
should get in this debate?
MALKIA CYRIL: No.
What's happening is this--
we have an FCC
chair, the Chairman
of the Federal Communications
Commission, who is--
let's say-- so first, he decided
to eliminate broadband privacy
rules that had been
hard-fought and won.
He just eliminated
the prison phone
rules that we won also that
lowered the cost of calls
from prison.
So he eliminated those.
And when I say
"eliminated," what he did
was he refused to
fight for them,
and so the court
eliminated them.
And so it's in that context.
It's in the context
of an FCC chairman,
chosen by Donald
Trump, who is rolling
back all of the civil
and consumer rights
policies that have been won
over the last five years.
So the attack now on net
neutrality, the justifications
that are being used are,
one, it's bad for investment.
Well, demonstrate to me
any evidence of that.
Because they can't.
There's no evidence of that.
So it's a talking point.
And they keep saying it
will hurt smaller ISPs.
But the actual evidence that
has been produced/demonstrated
that actually those small ISPs
have thrived over the last five
years of which net
neutrality has been--
over the last three
years that net neutrality
has been the rule of the land.
The second justification they
give is it's not necessary.
We've been doing fine for
the last however many years.
It's good.
And I'm thinking
to myself, it just
reminds me of when people
marched on the South,
and Southern white
sheriffs said,
why do you want
to come up in here
and stir up the good Negroes?
We fine.
We don't have any problems here.
So this is the thing--
they're fine because they're
talking about a status
quo that was never fine.
And why we need rules
in the first place
is because there's been
a concentration of power,
corporate power,
that will further
deny people of color--
not only black,
but other people
of color as well,
and poor people across race--
the opportunity to speak.
That's why we need
those rules in place.
So, no, I don't think
that net neutrality
as a civil rights issue
is, at this point,
under the current
administration,
going to get any play at
all, unless we make it so.
If we do it, yes.
And we're going to have
to step up our tactics.
I believe that it's
not like before where
we could go in and negotiate
with semi-reasonable people
and have a conversation.
It's not like that.
This is now.
Let me tell you what they did.
People did a protest at
the FCC, and so the FCC
banned them for life.
You can't do that.
That's illegal.
You can't ban people
for life from a public--
you can't do it,
but they did it.
That's what they said.
They told them they can't
wear any t-shirts that
say anything about
net neutrality--
only about net neutrality.
You could wear t-shirts
about other things.
You can't do that.
That's a First
Amendment violation.
You cannot do that.
So this is what we're
dealing with right now.
So this is not a
reasonable situation.
It is beyond the question
of net neutrality.
I don't even like the
term "net neutrality."
As a black person, you know
the internet is not neutral.
We know that.
So whatever, you
know what I mean?
I'll speak their language
so we can get it done.
But what we need is
we need some equality.
We need some justice.
And that's what
we're fighting for.
WILSON WHITE: So I'm
going to stick there,
because in that answer
there were some tech issues
kind of woven in there.
So we're at Google,
big tech company.
Even on the net
neutrality conversation,
we're very much
involved with that.
But thinking more broadly
about tech and civil rights,
what role do we
play, should we play,
as a tech company in the
modern civil rights movement,
both at Google and the
tech industry generally?
MALKIA CYRIL: Yeah.
It's a big question,
but I think there's
some really clear
points of intervention
that tech companies
should make in general.
I like to follow this
four-pronged approach.
I call it "digital sanctuary."
It's my own way I think about
it, so I'll share it with you.
One is we talk about--
sanctuary legally
has been a term
used when cities and states defy
federal laws that they think
are immoral or unjust, or
that they think are actually
illegal, that violates
parts of the constitution
or violate basic human rights.
And that term has
come up in terms of--
within the movement around
undocumented immigrants, right?
But I think that we're
at a point where the term
"sanctuary" does not only
and should not only refer
to undocumented immigrants.
It should refer to
all those whose civil
rights have been violated or
truncated by this country,
within this country.
So when I think about
digital sanctuary,
I'm thinking about
basically, what
are the tech policies,
practices, and practitioners
that we need to extend
human rights to all people?
Civil and human
rights to all people.
So I think about
it in four ways.
One is I think that we need the
tech industry to demonstrate
some level of defiance.
I think that it is not time
to maintain the status quo.
To me, it is never that time.
But as long as you
have vast inequalities,
that time never exists.
But I think, in particular,
technology companies
on some level are
the line between
serious authoritarianism and
some measure of resistance.
There is a corporate
class here that needs to--
a part of the business class
that needs to fight back.
And that needs to be very
clear that if it sides only
with shareholders and
those who are profiting,
it will lose its consumer base.
Because consumers--
all the rest of us--
need protection.
And there is a question when
you're dealing with a giant.
And right now, a consolidated
federal government is a giant.
It is a beast.
It is a monolith.
And it is crushing
people right and left.
You need a giant
to fight a giant.
And I think that some of
these big tech companies
need to be that giant.
They need to be giants for
civil and human rights.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
So I would say
defiance is an order.
And that means defying
things like the Muslim ban.
When we talk about
Muslims, you think
we're talking about some people
over there in the Middle East,
somewhere else.
But first of all, let's
be clear that Muslims
exist all over the world.
Let's be clear that in the
United States, 40% of Muslims
are black.
So this is an issue
concerning black people.
And when we look at the
sisters in Washington State,
in Portland, who were
attacked, and then
the three white men
stepped in and two of them
lost their lives, one of
those sisters was black.
The other sister was a
Middle Eastern Muslim.
My point is this is a black
woman, a Muslim woman--
black Muslim woman.
So I just want to be
clear, this is an issue
that affects black people.
So the Muslim ban, defy it.
Defy it from gate to the end.
All of these extra
legal requests
for data by law
enforcement agencies?
Defy them.
Say no.
Even if it's against the
law, the law that they set.
Because these are laws that
they're creating right now.
They're just making them.
Executive orders?
That's the law.
You have to choose whether you
will comply with it or defy it.
And there comes risks with that.
But I'm going to
tell you, as somebody
who puts my body on the line
in protests on a regular basis,
I feel like, yes, put
your money on the line.
Put your money on the line.
That's what we need to do.
I think another piece--
we talked about defiance,
so there's that.
So let me just
say this, defiance
is about not giving
up your data.
Don't give it up.
And I think that
there's all kind
of complicated lines in there.
There's questions of terrorism,
counter-terrorism work.
And I understand that.
I also understand that
within the conversation
about counter-terrorism
and terrorism,
black people are being
cast as terrorists.
And so there has to be a line.
There has to be a line drawn.
Whereas, white
supremacists, for example,
are not being cast
as terrorists.
White supremacists who drive
their cars into mosques.
White supremacists who
slit people's throats.
actively kill people,
they are not be
considered terrorists.
But Black Lives Matter
who protest and march.
And maybe somebody-- a random
person might throw a garbage
can through a window.
I don't know nothing about that.
But what I'm saying is
that is property damage.
These people are slitting
people's throats.
They are killing people.
And they're not being
considered terrorists.
So there's a context for
these requests for data,
and we need to defy them.
I think that tech companies
need to, obviously,
be very active and not only
to fight for an open internet,
but all of the
ways in which folks
are trying to maintain
an open, secure,
and affordable internet.
So whether we're dealing
with the questions
that fiber brings up, or
whatever the case may be.
Working with local coalitions,
working where people are,
and divesting from
white supremacy.
And I know this was
a challenge, right?
When during the election
cycle of Donald Trump--
and folks were saying, don't
give this man no money.
What is wrong with you?
Don't do it.
A lot of tech companies
struggled with that.
They were like, well, we give
some to the left and some
to the right.
This is not a zero sum game.
It's not a level playing field.
You don't just give some
to the left and some
to the right side.
That's not how this works.
You either support
hate or you don't.
You either invest
in white supremacy
or you divest from it.
There's no place in the middle.
That's it.
Either you support it,
and you help it grow,
and you foment it,
and you allow it--
you give it food.
You allow it to feed on
your profits or you don't.
Or you starve it.
That's the choice that I think
tech companies need to make.
[APPLAUSE]
WILSON WHITE: I have
a few more questions.
I definitely want to dive
in on a couple of those.
But I'm going to open
it up to the audience
now for a few questions.
See what's on top of
mind for you guys.
AUDIENCE: So my question
was around the concept that
was mentioned [INAUDIBLE],,
like suspended compression
being like a bird cage.
And there's like all
these different pieces
that encapsulate--
that include mass incarceration.
How do you connect all
the different people
who are fighting for
these different issues?
So whether it be the
social responsibilities
of tech companies, whether it be
different rights action groups.
Everyone's doing these
kind of initiatives,
but how do we stay
on the same page,
so we're actually-- instead
of just standing on one piece,
then it's like another
piece is replaced by that?
How do we stay seen?
WILSON WHITE: How
do we make sure we
have a comprehensive
approach to this
rather than a piecemeal tackling
various components of an issue?
MALKIA CYRIL: Well, I think
that we look at the root.
So there are some core
things that are going on.
One is we see that there is
a rise of authoritarianism.
And that authoritarianism
is resulting in--
has a variety of impacts
on different issues.
But at its core, that rise of
authoritarianism is a problem.
And the rise of authoritarianism
coincides with the rise
of explicit white supremacy.
So if we can have a very
clear analysis, number one,
that helps us to connect issues.
So we talk about-- whether we
talk about mass incarceration
or climate change,
for example, we
know that our inability to
affect the federal government
right now is a problem.
So that's one kind of like big
lens through which we can look.
Number two, if we
just really get
clear that the concentration of
wealth and economic inequality
is a partial cause
of racial inequality,
if we can be clear about that
relationship, the relationship
between the economy
and the civil society
issues of racial inequality,
that helps us also.
So if we don't have to segment
into mass incarceration
or education or--
these are effects,
you know what I mean?
These are all effects.
If we can focus on causes,
then we can stay clear.
WILSON WHITE: There's a
question on the Dory, which is
our internal questioning list.
SPEAKER 1: Let's
take this question.
WILSON WHITE: All right.
So can net neutrality
be a reparations
of sorts for groups that have
had their histories hidden
by media ignoring
or misrepresenting
their narratives?
I think of the way Native
Americans and African Americans
have been portrayed over time,
and how net neutrality can open
pathways for community media.
MALKIA CYRIL: Let me take the
second part of that question.
Absolutely, net
neutrality can open
pathways for community
media and community voices,
allowing a little--
small dogs to be heard.
The big dogs don't get to
take up all the airtime.
That said, I think the
fight for reparations
is a different fight.
I think it's a necessary fight.
I think people don't understand
what reparations means.
A lot of times, you
say reparations,
people think, oh,
I want my money.
Let me get my money.
And the thing is
it's not about that.
It's about shifting power.
Because one of
the reasons that--
when slavery was
proclaimed over and there
was a whole period
in American history
called the
reconstruction, right?
And where there were all those
promises made to black people
about what we were going to
get for our hundreds of years
of enslavement.
And none of those
things came to pass.
A handful of people
got their 40 acres.
Most people did not.
And the reason
that that matters.
Like today-- I don't you if you
know, but today is Juneteenth.
Juneteenth!
[APPLAUSE]
And why that's important is
all around the country today,
black people are doing an
action called 40 Acres, 40 Days,
and taking back land all
over this country today.
And why that
matters, I think, is
because when we take
back physical land,
there's a correlation
to the digital space we
have to reclaim as well.
And that's part of how
I see the relationship
between this fight
around net neutrality
to this fight around land.
We have to actually--
land matters, right?
Native Americans understand
that because their people were--
genocide against our
indigenous brothers and sisters
was for the land
and for what was
inside of the land or water--
the natural resources.
Folks didn't just steal
Africans from Africa.
They also stole gold, ivory, and
all kinds of other resources.
So when we understand how
Europe and America came
to have the level of
wealth that they do.
And we understand
that that wealth
is built on stolen property,
on the theft, on laws broken,
on lives and bodies broken,
then we can actually
understand reparations in
a completely different way.
You don't need to give me
something that I haven't heard.
It ain't about that.
You stole from the people.
You stole from the
people in order
to create your own wealth.
And that wealth now needs
to belong back to the people
that you stole it from.
And so that's the
same idea when we
think about digital equality.
We're also talking about
claiming digital space,
claiming that space, giving it
to those whose content actually
is your bank.
That's where you're
getting your money
from is all the people
that's actually online.
SPEAKER 1: Question
in the back here.
WILSON WHITE: I'll
repeat the question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
WILSON WHITE: So
tell me what this
has fared-- but essentially, can
we attack some of this problem
through the educational
system at the earliest ages,
getting young people to see
the world in a broader context
and not using educational
system to deconstruct
some of these
preconceived biases that
are baked into society?
MALKIA CYRIL: So
they did a study
and they found that
by the age of five,
children already very
serious racial biases.
And that's before
you've gone to school.
So I just want to say that
to start out with, right?
I think it's
important-- a couple
of things that are important.
One is my sister actually
runs a daycare center.
And it's a daycare center
focused on black children.
It's an Afrocentric
daycare center.
And they drum in the morning
with their little djembes,
and they have a
cute, little time.
But one of the reasons that I
think is so important that she
has this daycare center--
it's called Little Maroons--
is because, actually, we
have to teach each other how
to be free.
And I think that
freedom is something
that I think black people
in the fight for freedom,
this constant quest for
freedom, is something
that black people have
generously and brilliantly
offered to the rest of society.
Because actually,
the fight for freedom
is not only a fight
for black folk.
It's also a fight for everyone
else, including white folk.
The white folks are
imprisoned by white supremacy
the same way the jailer
is imprisoned by the jail.
So what I want to say is this.
Yes, the educational system
is part of the infrastructures
that produce meaning.
When we think about media,
we think about technology,
we also should be thinking
about the educational system
as part of that setup, right?
But the goal should not
be to teach children not
to see each other,
but to see people
as not black or not white.
I am black.
I would like to be seen as such.
And with my blackness comes
a history and a positioning
in society and a struggle.
And it's very rich and I
think it has a lot to offer.
So I don't believe that
we should be teaching
our children to be colorblind.
I think that that
is actually false.
I think we should be
teaching our children
to be freedom fighters.
And we should be teaching
them how to survive.
Throughout history, if
you live by the river,
you teach your child where
to go in the river, where
not to go in the river.
You teach your children
how to survive around fire.
You teach them how to
live in the context
and natural environment
that is around them.
We also have to
teach our children
how to live in the political
environment that is around
them.
And so that means--
we used to have home
economics classes.
But you know, when are we
going to teach our children
how to balance
checkbooks and how
to protect themselves online?
All of this is
part of being free
in the political
environment that we are in.
So number one, let's
teach our children
to be freedom fighters.
Number two, let's not teach
them to be colorblind.
Number three, yes, let's
use the educational system,
but understand that all those
same biases are baked in.
So if you want to use
the educational system,
we actually need to
organize around that.
We need to change
the curriculum.
We need to change how
teachers are trained.
It's not just about teaching
kids to be nice to each other.
You feel me?
We need to actually
train them to organize.
All over the world people know
who the president of the United
States is.
Do you know who the
president of Mozambique is?
I'm just saying,
we dumb up in here.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm telling you, you might know.
Did you raise your hand?
AUDIENCE: I'm actually
asking a question.
MALKIA CYRIL: Oh, you're
asking a question?
I don't know either.
I'm dumb, too.
I'm saying we have a
terrible educational system.
You know what I'm saying?
We got little children in
Palestine running around,
know exactly what's going
on up in United States.
Feel me, we do
not know the same.
Adults do not know the same.
So there is an entire
overhaul that we
need in our education system.
And I can tell you,
Betsy DeVos is not
going to bring that to you.
She's not going to
do that for you.
WILSON WHITE: I'm not
going to touch that one.
MALKIA CYRIL: I'm just going
to be the one to say it myself.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So first, thanks for coming.
This is a great conversation.
I want to just get
back to something
that you mentioned earlier.
You talked about basically,
like the criminalization
of black as itself, right?
And how that gets
perpetuated in the media
as the media being
part of the problem.
One thing I'm
curious about is as--
Father's Day was just
yesterday, right?
The narrative has been for years
that black fathers are absent,
right?
And then, a couple years ago,
they do an actual study on it.
And they find that black
fathers are the most involved
in their children's lives.
Yet, that narrative
is not the narrative
that's going to still be talked
about day in and day out.
So when people talk
about black parents,
they're still thinking
that they're absent.
I'm curious about
your thoughts on--
how do we spread
these narratives
and make those the
new stereotypes
that we give to black folks as
opposed to the negative ones?
MALKIA CYRIL:
Transforming narratives
is a long-haul project.
People think that we can
insert some new talking
points, messages, and there's
going to be a new story.
But these narratives
aren't about what's said.
These narratives are
produced by how things are.
Do you understand
what I'm saying?
Communications
experts always are
very interested in neuroscience
and how people think,
and how to make brain maps
and understand information.
And one of the
things that is clear
is that simply
telling people facts
doesn't change
what they believe.
You know what I mean?
They'd be like, you lying.
They'd be just like--
WILSON WHITE: Fake.
MALKIA CYRIL: Yeah.
That's fake.
That's not real.
And that's because everything
else affirms the lie.
So all the way to the--
if you over-incarcerate
black people,
you have one or two
explanations for that,
either racial discrimination
or black criminality.
That's it.
Those are the two explanations
for over-incarceration.
We can produce facts that
demonstrate racial bias, which
we have many, many times.
And yet, you have a huge
portion of the population
that believes that the
answer is black criminality.
And you cannot convince
them otherwise.
So I'm of the mind that while
narrative change is necessary,
I'm of the mind that it will
come about because of material
change.
We actually have
to change the laws.
We actually have to change
the way judges work.
We actually have-- we have to
change the material conditions,
and those will begin to
affect the narrative.
Kwame Ture said, it don't
matter if you want to lynch me.
It matters if you have
the power to lynch me.
So you could say or
believe whatever you want.
That's fine.
You could think that
black fathers are absent
all day and night if that's
what you want to believe.
But do you have the power to
then defund black families?
Because if you do as a
result of that stereotype,
that's where I feel like
we need to make the change.
I think simply saying new
things, it doesn't work.
It doesn't work when an entire
system around those words
tells you something else.
WILSON WHITE: I think we have
time for two more questions,
if we have any from
the audience here?
All right.
Oh, we have one.
And I have the last one.
MALKIA CYRIL: When he
said two, he meant one.
AUDIENCE: Do you
predict a resurgence
of very aggressive
color discrimination
and other disenfranchising
ways to affect communities
in the future?
So my conflict with
this when I was
hearing about
[INAUDIBLE] election
and hearing about other
governments and other people
getting involved in it, it
reminds me really quickly
of [INAUDIBLE] in Tennessee.
It reminds me of very
quickly gerrymandering laws
that we've still struggled to
deal with the last 400 years,
right?
So I imagine in the
next few elections
we're going to see this in a
much more aggressive fashion.
Because not it's
physical gerrymandering,
it's actually along
the line of how
do I find the ways
to make it that you
can't get this information,
you can't make it
to the voting hall.
What do you think about this?
MALKIA CYRIL: I think that
it's not a prediction.
It's already happening.
I think that right
now, we are seeing--
in local elections, we're seeing
fierce voter intimidation,
particularly
throughout the South.
We've seen it in different
cities throughout the South.
We're seeing extremely
aggressive attacks that
aren't necessarily
correlated to voting,
but that are absolutely
targeted towards people
of color, particularly
immigrants, blacks, and Muslims
right now.
So I think this
dystopic future is here.
You know what I mean?
It's happening now.
And so I think the
question is, what are we
going to do about it?
And people are starting
to marshal defense forces.
We're in a scarier time
than I think people realize.
And this idea that any one of us
can stand by and be a bystander
is gone.
Either you do something
or you do nothing.
And that's where
I'm at right now.
So I definitely think it's
going to escalate, especially--
and it's going to
escalate around voting,
but it's going to escalate
also around natural resources.
I think people-- when you
talk about water wars,
like we're there.
People are fighting
right now for clean water
in various parts
of this country.
And those people
are black and brown.
Those people who cannot get
clean water are black and brown
people.
So that's part of
why I say when we
talk about the role
of tech companies,
it's not a romantic question.
Do you know what I mean?
It's not like esoteric.
It's not like moral, or you
should be on the side of good.
It's like, are you going
to protect life or are
you going to serve death?
That is where
we're at right now.
And so that is the question that
I would throw back out to you,
because that is where we're at.
Aggressive attacks
against people
that look like me,
and you, and others.
Aggressive attacks
against women.
I don't know if
you've noticed, but
many of these attacks
against Muslims,
they have been Muslim women.
Children, in fact.
They're teenage girls.
The young woman who was
just found beaten to death
and drowned in a
pond in Virginia,
a young Muslim
girl, 17 years old.
Yesterday, beaten to death.
This is where we're at.
Beaten to death by a
random dude who passed by.
Did not know her.
They're not
connected in any way.
So this is where we're at.
And we have a responsibility
to do everything we can,
anything we can to stop it.
WILSON WHITE: All right.
In 140 characters or less,
what keeps you up at night?
MALKIA CYRIL: Well,
I think I mentioned,
like I do believe tech companies
stand between a certain--
a heightened authoritarianism
and a heightened resistance.
And I think that I'm terrified
that they will choose
their profits over people.
I think that that is a
very likely scenario.
And the only way that
that will not happen
is because of people
who work there.
WILSON WHITE:
Well, Malkia Cyril,
thank you so much for
spending time with us today.
Take care of yourself.
[APPLAUSE]